I I don't I don't
I don't what's what I'm looking for it's
I completely understand no I know I
believe it because here's the thing like
I'm hard on games I've been my entire
life and I suggest you go by by God of
War I didn't see too many people say not
to buy God of War right so it deserves
the money deserves the the success it's
just all I'm saying is you know that
little cushion that it got from bundles
was there and you know sure probably
only equal to maybe a million or two uh
maybe a little bit more than that I
probably wouldn't say anything more than
three uh because they sold a lot of
those bundles during Black Friday almost
everything was bonded with God of War
Ragnarok so it's just it's good I I'm
enjoying it because I I've always been a
huge adamant on person if you make good
games you get rewarded they made a good
game they got rewarded but I I I'm
willing to say uh you know this this
this game makes me think they're gonna
be a place